Michael K Williams is multi
emmy-nominated actor he is one of those
who has had a few roles of a lifetime
Williams is best known for playing Omar
little the wily antagonist of drug
dealers on HBO's the wire and the
racketeer chalky white who loved him on
Boardwalk Empire he was also nominated
for playing Bessie Smith's husband in
the HBO biopic Bessie alongside Queen
Latifah now Williams his starring is
Bobby McCray the father of one of the
five New York City teenagers convicted
in the 1989 attack of a jogger in
Central Park for the upcoming series on
Netflix titled when they see us Kevin
Richardson said you raped a lady in the
park Michael K Williams we are just
thrilled to have you here
thank you so much you play Bobby McCray
as we said you were the father of Antron
and what is so tragic about your
character story is that he's the person
that tells him to confess to something
he did not do yes that had to be
incredibly gut-wrenching as an actor to
play yes it was gut-wrenching as an
actor but more so as a parent yeah you
know I just don't I don't understand
well today I kiss easy for me to sit
back and say I don't understand how he
can do that
however you know the circumstances the
lack of information that there are of
how the system works of what was legal
to what was not not accurate that mixed
with the fear of they instilled in him
with you know the threats of the police
threatened the father basically to
exposed to his job have been in jail
absolutely and so the father was
terrified I've told the son to confess
absolutely they put him in a horrible
position and you know it was
you know it was the ignorance he
actually believed when they told him
that you know if you get your son to
just you know go along with the story
you all get to go home yeah this is
something you were in New York at the
time when this actually happened and
this is what has been so interesting to
talk to some people about what do you
remember from that time that made you
then could sort of take to this as you
were playing this role you know I
remember the fear yeah that was rough
that's the main thing I remember I
remember now you know looking on the
news
hearing what they were being accused of
having only to go on what I was being
fed and went you know I heard that they
confess but then when I looked at them I
didn't I
I saw myself you know yeah you in your
20s then I would did 21 you know so this
could be me this easily could have been
me
yeah you know but I I also felt the fear
of not wanting to be generalized not one
to be loved in with whatever they said
these kids were doing me when you think
about these kids these five young men
you look at them it's it's such a hard
story to tell beautifully told what did
you take away from this for me I took
away just how easily that could have
been my family mm-hmm and what can I do
today to prevent that and the hope of
these young men this this this resilient
spirit well their you know their ability
to to move on and to grow the bar that
they share together is is nothing like I
guess we none of us can understand but
for me the way I want to talk to honor
them to show how much I appreciate what
they've gone through and what they've
overcome is by plain doing my part to
make sure that we starts create the
narrative that we start to change what
happened because there has to be
accountability
obviously on on the on the police on the
police and on our law maker side there
has to be accountability there that was
wrong
as from a man from my community that
looks like the community where they came
from yeah it's my accountability to
better educate myself better informed
myself with with the way things work and
to get to know my local
petitions and my local police office and
police officers and make sure that they
know me yeah and they hear my voice we
should we should say by the way the city
never apologized to those five I want to
get one thing we know one where is it no
one now came forth and said I'm sorry
for what you men went through no one we
mentioned we mentioned that that you
played Omar on the wire which President
Obama said was his favorite character in
the show what did you think when you
heard that I'd go up it was frightening
you know I wasn't living my best life at
that time and you know he goes to the
future president United States you know
singling me out for something that I had
done that he he he had it was it was a
little like whoa but what it did was it
set me on my journey I said well wait a
minute if this politician you know is
watching the wire and and and can
understand my character who was he right
you know because up until that point you
know I was a grown man on television who
thought my voice didn't matter so I
think I didn't I wasn't involved in my
community I didn't think that my input
matter
you saw power you know your hat that's
about to change and we see that in this
series I got a chance to watch it it's a
it's must-see for everyone it's really
powerful thank you so much for being
here
episode 1 of when they see us premieres
Friday on Netflix